[Music]
let's bring in Dave Rubin easily author
affirm this book a commentator familiar
face here on Fox News and of course
Emily still here Dave first off your
reaction to the burning of a precinct I
mean do we used to hear about this stuff
in Iraq
I never thought we're gonna see he
didn't see about to see hear about this
in America yeah you know one of the
things I say on my show all the time is
that two things can be true at the same
time what happened to George Floyd is an
absolute travesty and a criminal act and
by the way everyone across the board as
partisan as we are is condemning it from
what I'm seeing but let's be we have to
be clear about the other thing too which
is those are not protesters out there
those are rioters those are criminals
you cannot burn down stores you
certainly can't burn down police
precincts that that does not help
anything and yeah it does look like a
third world country out there and I
guess we're gonna send in the National
Guard I mean things are not looking good
Dave you're in Southern California what
when you see these images and this video
especially of that precinct just
exploding and all of the police cars
that were sort of fleeing I mean it was
incredibly powerful and obviously
horrible to say the least what does this
recall for you of the 1992 Watts Riots
yeah well you know what we need more
than anything else right now is the
exact same thing we need whenever this
type of thing happens whenever there is
an injustice and then there are riots
after in all this we need calm or voices
to prevail you know I just saw yesterday
that Al Sharpton is heading there now
and if you just look at what's happening
on Twitter and the rest of it I saw this
morning Ali Velshi on MSNBC I just
tweeted out this clip telling us that
you know that the rioters are mostly
peaceful meanwhile there's a building
exploding behind him it's like we need
we need some honest actors in this we
need an honest media and we need an
honest politician or two would be nice
that's what we need more than anything
else because otherwise these
especially in an age of social media
they just continue to escalate there's a
lot of people that want chaos right now
and you know in this strange time that
we're all living in through Corona it's
like we don't need more fuel on the fire
literally so we just need some adults in
the room I think you guys are doing a
nice job of it and I'll continue to do
the same and I just wonder what law
enforcement tactic is I know they have
their hands full but a neighboring city
should have provided additional law
enforcement 500 National Guard Iza is
not enough 500 is way too little puts
everybody in danger and it seems as
though reporters are saying no sirens no
police presence they watched as things
happen on the outside and we saw the
chaos that's taking place I don't know
if it's gonna happen again on day four
but I don't know how the people of
Minnesota should be tolerating this even
with the outrage of his death meanwhile
let's switch over to Trump first Twitter
and yesterday the president watching all
this hell said these thugs are just dis
honoring the memory of George Floyd and
we won't let that happen again
just spoke to the governor and told him
the military is on its way any
difficulty we'll assume control but when
the looting starts the shooting when the
looting starts the shooting starts thank
you Twitter saw that they basically put
disclaimers with it so you have to read
the disclaimers before it happened and
the president just tweeted in response
of Twitter acting again on him since
we're doing nothing about all the lies
and propaganda being put out by China or
the radical left Democratic Party
they've targeted Republicans
conservatives and the president itíd
state section 230 should be revoked by
Congress until then it will be regulated
where's this war going Dave oh man I
mean for those of us that are that are
in this war might my show is on YouTube
distributed as a podcast and the rest of
it it's like the free speech war has
been burning for the last three or four
years and it seems finally now it is
coming to a head most of your audience
probably knows generally speaking I fall
more on the libertarian side where I
don't like the idea of say government
regulators working with big tech I don't
like that but Trump actually using this
executive action to take away
protections so that Twitter has to
behave Twitter and YouTube and goo
there are some so that they have to
behave more honestly I don't see that as
a problem because that's just taking
away a legal protection but even with
that we have to be careful for what we
ask for because if they have less
protections they then might start
policing speech even more carefully but
of course this is Twitter taking direct
aim at Trump and Trump supporters
because we know all day long on Twitter
I mean you could just search the the
George Floyd or the Minneapolis hashtag
I mean there are literally thousands of
people rejoicing in violence calling for
violence every time Trump tweets there's
there's people off in blue check
journalists threatening him Kathy
Griffin with her tweet about the syringe
with air in it on Trump this week I mean
there's a series of these things and and
that really is what this is about
it's the selective decisions that they
make that somehow always seem to be
against right leaning or conservative
people but I think this thing is just
gonna keep ramping up throughout the
election and and for those of us that
care about Liberty that care about
choice and freedom we're gonna have to
decide are these the platforms that we
want to be on are there other ways
around it you know I'm a competition guy
and I think there will be some solutions
on the horizon that's exactly right Dave
and I think it's important to remember
too that it's not just the tag that
because they have flagged it no one is
able to like or retweet it so you lose
that amplification effect and that's why
it's obviously censorship because it
can't go any further so there's sort of
multiple degrees of the impact that
Twitter is having on this and and by
Twitter we mean individual actors that
are working there and getting paid to
act as these arbiters thank you for
joining us Dave if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlists all right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell